one of the most important checks on
government power is a free and
independent press this is it's one of
the building blocks upon which the
United States of America is built and I
want to put aside for now sort of the
pragmatic reality that media is often
taken over by corporate interests in the
United States but focus more on the
existence of media as an institution the
Trump administration has been attacking
the media as the enemy of the people
rather than saying this is a crucial and
fundamental necessity in democratic
societies that's what we do you would
want to hear from someone who claims to
defend the Constitution and checks and
balances and the sort of foundational
tenets of the United States but instead
what we've heard from Trump is that the
enemy of the people is the media and
this is particularly boneheaded
considering that the right who talks
about needing to protect themselves from
a tyrannical government and wanting
rifles and handguns to do it the reality
is that a free and independent press is
one of the best protections you can have
against the tyrannical government that
they claim to fear it almost is like
they just say that in order to justify
having even more guns tons of examples
of Donald Trump framing media as bad for
America one tweet just as an example
from last year Donald Trump saying the
fake news media bailing New York Times
NBC News ABC CBS CNN is not my enemy it
is the enemy of the American people and
there are countless iterations of this
trying to frame the media as an enemy of
Americans at large it has now been
brought to my attention by a few of our
viewers the the Trump administration or
the Trump campaign or the Trump
Organization it's a pretty blurry line
between these organizations at this
point have sent out a survey to
Republicans called the media
accountability survey which is basically
meant to do two things number one it's a
total push poll and I'll explain what
that is in a second it's a total push
poll to push people into certain beliefs
and number two it's a survey meant to
generate one-sided results which they
can then use
to justify even more subsequent attacks
on media outlets that are doing really
good critical reporting on Donald Trump
so let's look through this a little bit
the certified website of President
Donald J Trump sent out the mainstream
media accountability survey and this is
truly a crook a clinic on push polling
let's look at these first two questions
okay if you wanted to do this fairly
like if we pretend they actually wanted
less biased data instead of saying do
you believe the mainstream media
actually cares about working Americans
which is the way that they worded it you
would instead say please rate the degree
to which you feel the mainstream media
represents the interest of working
Americans and you might have options
like they always do they mostly do they
sometimes do stuff like that
second question also a push poll
question do you believe that the
mainstream media has unfairly reported
our president our presidency that is a
push question again if you wanted to
ascertain this in a more fair way you
would say please rate the fairness of
the mainstream media on the presidency
mostly fair always whatever right I
think you understand the way that it
would sort of go next another question
is just a sampling on which issues does
the mainstream media do the worst job of
representing Republicans and then you
can check off as many as you want
immigration economics Perle pro-life
values religion whatever the case may be
I'm not gonna go through the entire
survey but you sort of get the picture
and what's notable here isn't that there
push polling that's actually really
common the notable thing is that a
concerted effort is being made here by
Trump himself and speeches and in
interviews by Trump's advisers who have
started to pick up on this the media is
the enemy thing and now by this survey
to turn media to turn people rather
against the media and this survey is
being promoted with huge ad dollars we
have started to get emails from people
saying David there are ads appearing on
your videos on YouTube promoting the
survey they are buying ad space all over
the Internet
if you go to the Trump supporting forums
on the internet you will see that this
is working if you go to I don't even
name it but I think some of you know a
particular Enclave within a major
Internet message board of discussion
you'll see Trump is there saying stuff
like quote and I'm quoting here the
media is the next target so let's take a
step back and see if we can understand
what's going on here they claim that
they're for the Constitution and for law
and order they're interfering in
investigations carried out by the
Justice Department they are
contradicting they're supposed support
of checks and balances they're making
deals with Supreme Court justices to get
them to agree to retire they're
attacking freedom of the press and the
value and importance of media as a check
on government power but they want you to
think that they have your interests in
mind and that they support the
Constitution and separation of powers
and checks and balances this is a danger
now that is far bigger than Trump and if
it's not resisted and I don't see enough
resistance going on we are going to see
the total subjugation and co-opting of
what is arguably one of the top three
meta issues I would say it is without a
doubt one of the top three meta issues
that we're dealing with which are of
course campaign finance the climate and
media media consolidation media
ownership net neutrality if we allow the
media to be framed as the enemy of the
people it is going to become
increasingly difficult to maintain even
a putative democracies which some would
argue we don't even really have here and
the fundamental just basic respect of
not an individual media outlet because
that's not what this is that's the
important thing
but just a respect for the fact that we
need free and independent press in this
country if you're not as concerned about
this as I am I want to hear why because
this should be red alert crisis in
everyone's minds I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show we'll take a quick break and
be back after this